I'm definitely someone who leans more
towards like a warm cozy vanilla kind of
a smell one that I really love and I
thought was so different than anything
I'd ever seen before was Pat McGrath
putting the foundation in the palm of
her hands and warming it up in her hands
before applying it to the skin that was
just something that I had never seen
before and
she's mother so we listened to what she
says probably last year I loved my Met
Gala look last year and I loved my brown
sonorant dress for the Academy Museum to
have my own Beauty line feels amazing
and to have it finally be available in
the UK feels even more amazing